want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the seven rich people habits that you
need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one have a vision with richard montagnes
there isn't anything that you can't
accomplish
if you have vision
you see
when i started with frito-lay 1976
i didn't have a whole lot of going for
me
i had no education
i was told i would never be anything
but i had one thing i had vision
and this is what vision did for me
when others saw what i was
vision saw what i would become
[Music]
the very thing that disqualified me
vision used to qualify me happy number
two value what you do i
appreciated the job i valued it i
i liked
and appreciated the responsibility and
the consequences of it and at any given
moment if i wanted to stop i could have
made it stop and i didn't so loved is a
funny word because obviously when you're
you know some of the things i had to go
through at the time and some of the
press and
some of the testimony and certain
circumstances and the pressure and can't
say gosh i loved every moment of it
but i always appreciated it and the
weight of responsibility
i valued because we were always in the
arena
you could always i could always have
stepped out and made myself an observer
but there's something about being in the
arena engaging in that thing and gosh i
wouldn't have traded any set of
experiences for the ones i had how about
number three just do it with jack dorsey
just do it
a lot of time is spent uh thinking about
something oh yeah and talking about it
yeah
but when you actually
get something down whether on paper
or in code or
uh
you know in front of someone that's when
things start happening and um
you're going to make a lot of
mistakes the important thing is that you
make decisions and you keep moving
forward
but you have to
get it out there yeah you have to start
and you have to be
brave enough to
to take the criticism i always go back
to the the punk movement of the 70s
people would get out they'd be on the
street
because you were a teenager back then
yeah and well
and they they would they would be uh
they would be learning in front of
people and like they get on the street
and it's the first time with a guitar
yeah and you know they're learning how
to play and they're getting better and
better and better yeah um and i think
it's really important to just
get it down do it just do it edit edit
edit edit also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
habit number four be empathetic with
john paul de jouria how many years in
foster care actually four and a half
years
yeah my mom was very very ill and we
were very young my brother and i so i'm
about five years old to nine and a half
years old in foster care we see our mom
on the weekends but during the week it
wasn't like it is today she had to work
to support us and there was no one to
take care of us really so monday through
friday we were in foster care and then
on the weekends with our mom
do you think being in foster care
allowed you gave you the tools to be a
successful entrepreneur i don't think
being in foster care gave me the tools
be not for you're a successful one i
think what it gave me was an
understanding about other people's lives
and understanding where they're coming
from especially the other kids are in
foster care with us didn't really have a
loving mom like we did yeah they didn't
get to see her on the weekends no they
they because the other weekends either
and a lot of them when they got out of
foster care had no place to go
you know they stopped you know
supporting them when they turned 18 or
graduated from high school they had no
place to go so i learned to be very
empathetic about others on this planet
that need that helping hand and i think
that was very beneficial when i finally
made it financially to be able to look
at the right things to invest money into
to help others out whether it's so
homeless or whether it's job programs in
l.a in texas we overcame a home a
homeless problem there that the world's
going to learn from wow we got a piece
of land we all contribute this is we the
people not the city okay we all
contributed we built
240 little houses
all for homeless people now who gets a
priority going in if you're without a
shelter for a year or uh
disabled you're our first priority
coming in you have a home we have
organic gardens there we have metal shop
wood shop craft shop theater we have
everything you ever imagined there right
so they could get they could work they
can make money while they're there and
have a safe place of life to clean their
lives up it's worked out so well that
many of our volunteers there are very
successful financial people but moved
there for one year in a trailer on our
properties little houses to let their
kids grow up showing and help out one
another what's amazing habit number five
have core values with robin sharma you
said that
everybody should have core values what
is what are some of your most deeply
cherished core values
service above self
in other words contribution impact
service
number two
family
i mean
if i could be a tenth of the human being
my two children are i'd be a
i'd be a i'd be a amazing
family you know i've worked very hard
but i've
really
worked hard on my family too even trying
to be a great son
you know great brother all those things
because we all know to get to the last
day of your last
of your life and say i made a lot of
money and i got a lot of likes and i
sold a lot of books and i impact a lot
of people
and your own family never got to know
you that's heartbreak
third value i'm an ask that the french
word lover of beauty
you know that's why you know that's why
i love los angeles like we were coming
over here and it's like
there's flowers you know it's whatever
time of the year is the flowers
everywhere you know
um so i love beauty and art and food and
people and sunsets and that's why i love
rome so much now that fourth value would
be um vitality
you know i i really do believe that
the the one of the keys to legendary is
longevity i mean i want to live until
177 i want to you know
right i mean i'm biohacking and i'm
resting and i'm doing the two massage
protocol and everything possible
so i can be rocking my craft and serving
as many people as possible when i'm into
you know i mean one of the things i'd
say is you never want to let an old
person anywhere near the inside of your
body right
because and when you get into
epigenetics and the fact that
we have a chronological age and a
biological age but vitality is important
and then i think the
final core value is lifestyle
you know we can serve the world and
that's very important i know to both of
us
but i want it's life is ultimately a
really short ride
and so i want to really be around only
people
i mean i am focused i only want people
in my orbit that bring me joy or fuel my
joy
i only want to do the pursuits in my
business and career and life that bring
me joy
and i only go to places where i feel joy
habit number six work with purpose with
indra nuyi as millennials have come into
the workforce in large numbers their
expectations of companies have changed
they no longer look at it as sort of a
paycheck but they look at it as how can
i go to work and make a difference in
society so the notion of purpose is
becoming a much bigger factor the big
difference is that in the past purpose
used to be
some sort of a corporate social
responsibility program and typically
those programs were good people like
them
but they were at the whim or fancy of
the ceo who was there so if the ceo
retired that program got cut
so we had to weave purpose into the core
business model of the company how do you
make sure that the sense of purpose
can only be accomplished if you make
profits
and the only way to make profits is
through purpose and that's why we you
know use the term performance with
purpose linking both together and i
think that's what's
excited millennials in particular and
what's excited the boomers to even stay
longer in the workforce because they
actually feel they're contributing to
the future of society as opposed to
walking and picking a paycheck and
leaving and habit number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is have heroes with mark zuckerberg
there are probably a lot of people who
can who can run microsoft and do a
reasonable job when i was growing up
bill gates was my hero oh come on yes
he's like darth vader he's not he's not
luke skywalker he's the bad guy no he is
not
um bill gates
ran
one of the most mission-driven companies
that i can think of right and you know
right now i think microsoft their
mission is less focused than it used to
be but when i was thinking about
you know what i wanted to be when when i
grew up you know microsoft i thought had
had a great mission put a computer on on
every desktop and in every office right
or maybe it was every desktop and every
home uh but
and
you know i mean there are companies that
define themselves by a way of doing
things right i mean there's um then like
the hp way that i was talking about and
there are companies that define
themselves by making a concrete change
in the world
and um
you know microsoft did that
and i like i have a huge amount of
respect for for him for doing that he
pushed them and it was an incredibly
inspiring company um during the time
that he was doing that i think that
they're they still are doing a lot of
things but i think that they've lost
some of the focus and um i don't know i
mean i think he's like one of the one of
the greatest visionaries that our that
our industry has ever had
you are capable of more i just want to
tell you to remind you that you are
capable of more that this struggle
that's in front of you right now that
seems all-encompassing and impossible to
overcome it's not your max
you can handle it because if this is
your max then you don't grow and you
don't become the person that you know
you're capable of becoming
this video will help so the most pain i
went through was when i was on my tour
last year and i broke my neck i broke my
neck i i fainted and and hit my head on
the wall and and broke my neck in two
spots i compressed my spine i had a
concussion which i've never had in my
life before
and i had to they put me in a neck brace
they put me in these and i wore this one
for
50 days or so and this one for 10 or
something like that it was 60 days of of
wearing something like this
and only be able to take it off for 10
minutes a day
that's it so i had to sleep in this i
had to have to shower in this i had to
do my speaking gigs in this and you can
see i don't know if you can see this
duct tape on here because this one was
more comfortable than this one
and so like i really didn't want to
break this one but just from use right
from having it on all day long
eventually it broke and my wife taped it
up and she wrote here i love you get
well soon love nina kind of like a cast
anyway this is the most painful thing
that i had to go through and the day i
broke my neck i was supposed to be doing
my speaking gig in in colorado and we
had to cancel that because obviously i
can't do it while i'm in the hospital
but then
came a really important time
what do i do next i don't know how
long a concussion lasts i don't know how
i'm gonna deal with the pain i haven't
really broken a bone in my body before
let alone two in my neck i didn't know
how safe it was to travel still do my
speaking gigs and the advice was rest
and go home you can't get on a plane
because of the compression but just just
drive home just rest and go home
and you know my age you wanted me to do
it the doctors want me to do it like i'm
not gonna go home i don't want to go
home
this is my chance to show myself what
i'm made of this is my chance to see
what i can do i'll let me at least try
let me at least try and it's very rare
that we actually get pushed to our
limits like our actual limits you're
pushed to your physical limits and you
can't do anything more and so my initial
thought was well forget that i mean
let's just
everybody who was supposed to come let's
just do something tomorrow
this is what i was thinking let's do
something tomorrow in our airbnb and
just have them come over and i'll lie
down on the couch or the bed and they
can ask me questions
i'm here to give value guys i'm here to
help let's go helping entrepreneurs is
gonna be healing for me and the doctor
like yeah you can't do that you you've
got a concussion you can't even think
clearly or properly like that's never
gonna happen so i had to refund
everybody in colorado and um and my next
stop was kansas city and we drove to
kansas city not too far away and
i was still feeling the massive pain
from the
from the neck but still the concussion i
hadn't recovered from my concussion and
i didn't know how long it was going to
last and i made a video
for the people who bought tickets in
kansas city canceling on them
and what i wanted to do was say hey i'm
here anyway
i'll give you your money back come to
the hotel
and i'll i'll still talk to you for as
long as i can go
and it was the morning
the day before in the morning i was
making a video i thought
i couldn't even finish making a video
i started getting dizzy halfway through
the video and so i i paused it and i
thought okay we should just we should
just cancel this like i i can't even get
through
uh two minutes of making a video
and so i tried again at night and i got
through the video and i said you know
what i don't know how long it will last
tomorrow i already booked a hotel
you know i'm not it's not it's
non-refundable for me uh you guys
already booked your tickets you booked
the time off in your calendar i'm going
to refund you the money because i'm not
going to go for four hours like i've
been doing in each city but
i'll go for as long as i can
if you want to show up and and i'll try
to help
and i went
for an hour and a half
and it was the greatest hour and a half
you know one of the greatest hour and a
half of my life and and my wife had to
then pull me off after an hour and a
half because i certainly get i didn't
even notice it but i was starting to get
you know woozy on stage
and um
it was great i was so pumped because
this was this was i'm done i've never
been pulled off a stage before
and here i was at my max
and i love the idea of pushing through
the pain obviously be healthy obviously
don't be
stupid but a lot of times we pull
ourselves back way too soon we don't
allow ourselves to actually test what
we're made of to see how far we could
actually go
and so i kept these
thanks to my friend mark draker i don't
collect things um i don't i don't have
souvenirs of stuff but he said you need
to collect you need to save them as a
souvenir of what happened as a memento
like all right whatever i'll keep it and
i look at this i'm like i'm crazy i did
that
60 days in this and kept going on tour
and we still did 10 more cities and i i
sat at the front of these stages
sitting down because i couldn't stand
properly and i had had like two or three
pillows behind me and an ice pack over
my right shoulder the whole time and and
still spoke for three to four hours
every day right
i still made videos you can go back on
my channel and you'll see me wearing
this with like this giant scab or scar
on my head because this is where i hit
my head on the wall
it's crazy this is a reminder of what
i'm capable of that whatever max i feel
like i'm facing right now is not my max
and i think you're capable of more as
well i think you'll learn more about
yourself
uh if you do it that way i bought my
first stock when i was 11. i was
actually i was at rose hill at the time
and i bought three shares of city
service preferred
at uh 38 and it went down to 27 which is
something i still remember even though i
was 11 at the time
uh and then it went up to 40 and i sold
it i made five bucks on my three shares
after commissions and then it went to
200 and something so
uh you know i i probably remember that a
little better than if i'd been doing it
on paper
and
i fooled around doing a lot of things
between about age 11 and 19 in the stock
market i did charts i did all kinds of
technical analysis i read every book i
could get on the subject
and
i didn't do that well i didn't do
terrible but but i did i was really just
floundering around
but by
that meant by the age of 19 when i read
ben graham's book i was at the
university of nebraska in lincoln i went
and bought this book called the
intelligent investor just come out and
it had an enormous impact on me
now if i hadn't done
in the previous eight years if i hadn't
been all over the lot i'm not so sure
that that book would have had the same
impact on me i mean i was by that time i
was prepared
to read ben graham's book which changed
my life financially in a an incredible
way i mean
uh
i wouldn't be up here today if i had
read that book but yeah part of life is
getting prepared
so that
when something does happen that's
significant
you can grasp the significance of it and
know what to do with it and i would say
that first eight years of fooling around
even though it produced nothing
financially to speak of
uh produced a lot in terms of getting my
mind prepared for when i really did read
something that made sense so i was ready
to accept it and i actually went back
and
went to columbia to study under the
under graham and
uh
because of
of reading that book and all kinds of
things flowed out of it you are one
decision away from changing your life
and you have to accept that your one new
meeting one new relationship one new
contact one new action
one new decision
away from shifting your life from where
it is right now to a totally different
place so what's the decision you already
know i could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave i don't know what it
is but i know there's a decision that
you need to make to take you to the next
level just like i know that's true for
me because decisions shape our destiny
when they're backed up by some massive
ass action
okay but you can't take the action if
you don't decide everyone say yes people
avoid being desperate think of the fact
they come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially their relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those of you that are achieving one
of the reasons the achievement has
slowed down is you've allowed yourself
to feel less desperate
when you were broke and starting your
business or when you were brand new in
your relationship and you were desperate
to get her to love you or desperate to
get him to love you you took massive big
action how many of you are moms in the
room raise your hand you mobs if you
woke up tomorrow morning and your baby
wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no
big time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take massive
action you searched the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you
you wouldn't would you have to have the
perfect plan to go find your baby that's
missing you wouldn't need any of that
because you were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all zen and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and i
want you to get desperate to make that
decision why because our obsessions
become our possessions which you obsess
about most regularly you will eventually
possess in your life the challenge for
most people sisters and brothers is that
we obsess on the things we're fearful of
what we don't have what we're worried
about and then we end up possessing
those things over and over again rather
than programming ourselves to become
obsessed with what we want what our
dreams are what we believe we deserve
when we become obsessed about those
things long term we end up possessing
those things can i get an amen for that
yes
yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our lives because
those things happen
naturally without thought the external
results of our life in order to replace
ourselves with the next best version
requires intention requires obsession
requires desperation everyone with me on
that say yes
so it's not unnatural to change
your friends that think you're crazy to
have started your business or come to a
seminar spend money you don't have
they're the crazy ones
it's unnatural to be the same person you
are right now next year for all of you
in here the 35 year old you should be
gone next year forever and there should
be a brand new better 36 year old
started the agency with 45 people that
didn't work in the industry i knew
nothing about the industry i read
nothing about the industry so i started
vaynermedia i built a creative shop that
i put media in the name
i had both media and creative under one
roof and had no idea that it was unique
so we were doing all these unusual
things
what it led to
is
a very large agency that has not played
by the industry rules but has driven
business results for its clients so now
we do have
900 people globally we do have the us la
and new york offices and
london and opening up singapore and
very frankly feel very confident we're
about to get a big scope for the world
cup in qatar and that means middle east
and looking at
you know
south america so i i think it's going to
be interesting to see what happens i
think
because of some of the awards we're
winning this week just i'm feeling from
the creative class here a little bit of
more of a
okay you can be in the club and i'm
laughing i'm like i don't want to be in
the club
i don't mind to be in the club
but there's only one club i want to be
in which is
wouldn't you want to be a creative that
in real life when you hang out with your
friends people know what you're talking
about
like how many more times do people here
want to spend 20 years of their life
making tvc that when they talk about it
and they're like you know the ibm spot
and their friends and relatives like i
have no idea what you're talking about
and if they do it's because they tried
really hard to find it
right um
i think that
people want to i think if you're
creative i think you want it to be seen
i just don't know what else to say and i
think you know what mike and adam will
tell you if you decide to yeah with them
after this is after having careers in
fancy places doing fancy stuff it's fun
to make
it you know think about all the ideas
that you guys have had that will never
see the day of life
like you guys are all 12 years away six
years away
four years away from being the final
decision maker to actually see something
made right now you're politicking
and and strategizing on how to convince
the two people above you to actually
make the thing you believe it
you're not in the creative industry
you're in the internal politicking
industry
that's why volume will set this industry
free
we have interns from day one
in ad school
being able to see their thoughts in
market from the biggest brands in the
world
literally in terms of we have literally
interns already in our company that have
had more pieces of content seen by
humans than some of the people here
that's real
that's going to play out i hope for all
of you i want you to be in a place where
you get to be creative for real instead
of
working at a bank
and uh
fighting for
a half pregnant version of your idea to
see the world
and that's why so many of you have to do
things on the side
because you can't scratch your itch
speaking of learning from lessons you've
been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs and i know you did a
reality show with richard branson says
10 12 years ago you said yes
what was that like and what's been a big
lesson you've learned from him and what
was the show and
what'd you learn yeah the show was
called the rebel billionaire and it was
the apprentice version richard branson's
version of that they were looking for 16
entrepreneurs so i'm like hey i'm an
entrepreneur i want to do this and i
really wanted to meet richard i sort of
had set intentions out there that i was
going to manifest him becoming a friend
in my life so when i heard about the
show i was like oh this is interesting
this might be how this happens so i
applied for it and um
uh it was wild so it's how big how big
was spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of it was
pretty i mean it was four years in it
was doing great yeah multiple seven
figures yeah my lawyers begged me not to
do it they're like what are you doing
you own this company you're gonna do a
reality show i was like i just want to
know richard i just feel like this is a
chance so um
so
yeah and and all the business challenges
took place around the world in different
cities and instead of if you didn't win
the business challenge going into a
board room to get fired you had to do a
crazy stunt like a world record breaking
stunt because richard is obviously
like a huge adrenaline junkie guy
so um in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9000 feet in the air on a
dangling rope ladder and have tea climb
to the top and have tea on top of the
balloon with richard it's insane it's
insane so what did you guys talk about
on the top oh my god i talked about like
how do we get down and that's what he
said you climbed back down i was like
what i didn't think about that it was so
scary yeah oh my gosh yeah so it took me
48 minutes to climb to the top it's at
the height of a 17-story building and
the dangling rope ladder was just like
hanging out into the abyss of
nothingness wasn't anchored to anything
so i'm like climbing it
and um there's cameras that was the
first day of filming so two months later
i know i like cameras up there
yes
helicopters circling
probably probably
i had to do all these crazy stunts the
next stone i had to do is i had to jump
off the side of the victoria falls gorge
in africa
on a with a bungee cord attached to me
and
my
guy on my team was dangling on a wire on
a crane
10 feet out from the cliff and each
person had to come up and stand there
and you couldn't run and jump and you
had to stand still and jump and if he
caught you you were okay and they'd put
you back on the cliff and if not you
fell 385 feet
on a bungee cord
and so i am be on terrified of heights
it's like one of my i'm so afraid of
heights i cry on airplanes still during
takeoff a lot of times
and
i was one of the only people to make the
jump richard didn't make the jump all
these other guys that were like amazing
athletes didn't make the jump and i like
to talk about this because i always talk
about aiming high and the importance of
aiming high in life and then i think all
of us we don't aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's saying you know if you shoot
for the moon if you miss you're at least
with the stars and afterwards everyone's
like sarah how did you make that jump
you're literally like the only
contestant and look at you i said well i
was aimed at the pulley six feet above
his head where were you aiming and i
aimed i didn't even look at him i aimed
six feet above his head and i landed at
his waist and he caught me and everybody
else was aiming at his face and landed
at his feet and missed
amazing so it's like a really just
poignant
example of the importance of aiming high
first enemy we all have
is doubt
you know we we doubt whether or not
we're capable we doubt whether or not
we're worthy we doubt whether or not
we'll succeed we doubt whether or not we
even deserve it and it's so unfortunate
because i think doubt is one of the
greatest enemies of our lives and it's
so easy to overcome but most people
won't practice the discipline of
overcoming it which is weird right they
say oh i'm so doubtful and they stop
and it's like if you have any negative
recurring emotion in your life doesn't
maturity require you to face it and say
hey how do i fix this you know if you're
always doubtful you can't just wander
around saying i'm so doubtful like some
kind of victim that's not fair to the
humanity you've been given that that
real power of free will that says hey
you can direct your consciousness that's
why you have this big prefrontal cortex
other animals can't we can so handle it
if you've been plagued without your
whole life then face it stop running
from it i know that sounds hard to say
to people but i was i had the same story
i was so doubtful that people would want
care about what i say i was so doubtful
that people would want to read my books
or listen to me at all i was so doubtful
that i could chase my own dreams and i
realized
for what reason am i doubtful
because of past failures in this space
no i'm trying something new because uh
people told me i might not be able to do
it so what makes them an expert on my
capabilities and my potentialities i
thought well why am i so doubtful we're
doubtful because the the germ of fear
spread in our body because somebody
planted it there one time or we
cultivate it with our own thoughts
and at some point maturity and
consciousness says if doubt has been
plaguing you let's have a look at it
and let's realize well how do you banish
it well every single
thing that we know from spirituality
from philosophy from the great writers
in the great text of human culture has
all revealed one thing where there is
doubt
grant me faith
that we have to have faith
and faith does not mean the absence of
doubt matter of fact the very definition
of faith we lies that doubt is still
there right you can't have faith unless
there's some part of you that says well
i'm going to go anyway despite the doubt
so i'm not saying we have to get rid of
doubt forever and handle it i'm saying
doubt should never prevent you from
advancing when you feel like advancing
that in your own mind you must say okay
i must trust in my abilities i must
trust that i will figure it out i must
trust that i can build it i must trust
that i can get some help and
progress
even though the doubt might be there
look the hero is a hero because the hero
does it anyway right even though the
hero's terrified and risking it all goes
anyway and we're all heroes in some way
we can all be courageous but i also
think you know what society overblows
courage society says you know courage
has to be some big magnificent act but
it's not i mean courage in this world
anymore is just having the the belief in
yourself and having the
the ability to genuinely express who you
are
if you're doubting yourself
the only way through is to give yourself
more faith and take more action and with
more faith
and more action comes more competence
with more competence comes more
confidence in psychology they call it
the competence confidence loop right the
more you learn and try the more you
master and develop so go out there even
with that yes let the doubt be there but
do it anyway you will find true success
and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
[Applause]
[Music]
people like michael stahlzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet and in
an instant this vibrant little boy
became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael and when this 13 year old man
was asked about his fellow amputees he
said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of 2013
you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams who came to harvard
four years ago
khadijah had attended 12 schools in 12
years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of 2013. the other thing you should do
if you're not very industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like get up early in the morning and get
your things done man learn to get up at
six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day down by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed and so
that's a massive massive advantage look
will ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author
he outlined data in why men earn more
which is a book i would recommend by the
way showing that if you work 13 longer
hours you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees
and one of them works an extra 10
percent it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tight
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 extra 13
percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is is for so
you can put in all sorts of things in
there you want to do and that would be
good for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to make vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down
and what because what are you going to
do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome basically what success meant
to me
uh was
the opportunity
to be useful so somebody else you know
might
entertain
me as a as a choice
but it also meant
that i could
i could use that
event of a success to do something
different than what was expected
i could go to another genre i could go
to another kind of role
i could go from the success of witness
to the opportunity of mosquito coast
right
and and uh and people say
wait a minute um
you know
uh
might not be the best career choice that
i thought well
i don't have to make the best career
choice
i have to make a choice that will uh
uh challenge me and be interesting for
me your attitude determines your
altitude if you're a positive person
positive things happen to you if you're
a negative person negative things are
going to continue to happen for you if
you can put that in your scope this year
just change your attitude wake up and
smile how about just wake up and be
grateful
it's just it's just common sense right
next thing
especially after a show like today life
is really 10
what happens to you and 90 what you do
about it look everybody in this room
everybody watching everybody got
something they got to deal with
get to dealing with it stop complaining
about it complaining about it only makes
it stay present do something about it
so life is ten percent what happens to
you is ninety percent what you do about
it and finally don't give up when
reaching your dream is difficult
listen if success were easy you've heard
it a million times everybody would be
successful it requires a grit and a
toughness to be successful but i got
news for you it's something that all of
you have in you now whatever you've been
through whatever that is guess what
you're still here you know what that
makes you a pretty tough person proverbs
12 11 he who works his land
shall have abundance
whoever chases fantasies lacks wisdom
there's my life
he who works his land what's my land tim
story if you're in the fifth grade work
in fifth grade land
if you're a single mother
work your land
if you're overweight
work your land get in shape
he who works his land
shall have
the word shall means certainly it's
fixed it's determined you shall have
what abundance abundance is overflowing
more than enough wow
i
am freakish at work in my land i am a
working machine i i'm in the middle of
eight companies
i'm doing movies at a high level i'm
doing plays
uh
rehab recovery which we'll talk about
later
uh i'm in the middle of the restaurant
business now
um i'm working my land
so
i'm up most mornings about 4 45
like you
i go to the gym
i'm working my land yeah so
vesantita gonzalez my mother when she
was so hard on me to do the dishes
correctly she was teaching me to work my
land
so one thing you will always get from me
is i will damn work my land i work my
land
and it gave me abundance
because it's the law of the harvest and
i'll work you through this it'll take me
literally 60 seconds do it you're going
to plow the ground
to plant the seed
to water the seed to get the harvest yes
so your whole life terrible the sower is
what's happened to you right okay
you you've been plowing plowing plowing
plowing plowing
okay hard work
planting planting planting planting by
faith yes watering by faith
and payday's on its way yes so payday
hit you and your wife yes in this
wild way why because it says it's going
to happen that's right he who works his
land shall have
abundance overflowing what are the
things you think you're not doing well
in your business
i think a lot of these have started to
shift with this book project so i tend
to be a person um there's this comes
from two places
i like to be involved in things because
i'm very collaborative yeah so i love to
see how things are turning out and i
love to like put my spin on them or at
least have my input um but at the same
time um you know that can be overbearing
i don't want folks to feel like they
constantly have to run things past me
you know my team definitely knows i
trust them um
so
the thing that i haven't done well in
the past is delegating enough letting go
enough control
and particularly with this project it's
pushed us all so far outside of our
collective comfort zones that it's been
a joy to be like you guys make the
decision you're amazing you're
intelligent you're smart whatever you
choose i'mma be happy with wow yeah
that's been good hard to do to let go of
that right it's been great it's been
good it's been really great like the
fact that i'm this like awake and happy
and and like in it right now speaks to
my
you know kind of let go and let jesus
take the wheel and in this case jesus
manifests as my team it's amazing just
let people make decisions and move on
yes you do what you need to do and let
everyone else do what they need to do
yeah it's the only way to sanity the
first thing to realize is don't believe
everything you see in movies and read in
books
you know there is no way both my wife
who worked for steve directly i worked
for steve could do that for 10 years
if there wasn't some amazing stuff that
came out of it it wasn't like we were
getting whipped every day it had nothing
to do with that
we were dedicated we were passionate he
was passionate
he wanted the best for the company for
the products for our customers
and when you're in that there's a
creative tension
and
he
emotionally would show that passion
sometimes sometimes it was oh my god
this is the best thing ever
you know you hear about the negatives
but you don't hear about all the
positives and all the great things he
did for you it did for the individual as
well as the company and all that stuff
so it was always a balance and those bad
days were not all very often but they
did happen because typically yeah
you might have made a mistake
don't do that again
or we weren't thinking about it right or
somebody was falling down on the job or
whatever the case may be
that's when it came out is when someone
didn't show respect for the mission they
were on when you didn't show respect for
the rest of your teammates and for the
thing we're trying to build that's when
there was a problem not when we were
falling when we fail when we tried
really hard and if we showed we tried
really hard then that was just an option
just like we the ipod phone was a
failure
no one got killed over that it was more
just a
you know okay we tried our best we move
on we tried our best we move on it's
when you were when you didn't
do what was right and you failed
from a because you didn't put your heart
and soul into it and you let the team
down
that's when there was a problem
and that's what people need to realize
it was very balanced and he was very
much human passionate and he was very
helpful and all kinds of stuff but yes
he did have his bad days
but not usually for without reason this
is where trainers mess people up
i've had trainers who totally just want
to prove that you could never
do what they do and
then they have you paying i know what
you mean just to say like oh this you're
not as good as me and they go to blast
you like they want you unless you're in
pain and you feel like you're sick and
you're throwing up you're like yeah
that's a workout now they look at you
yeah you hurt you can't walk great yeah
and the whole point is
what i tell people is treat the gym like
a spa the first time you ever go just go
in there and walk around touch the
weights get a drink of water walk around
and then leave
and i mean literally do that for like a
week two weeks until you just get to the
habit of getting in that door
because what's gonna happen is
eventually you're gonna start lifting
because you're there yeah and you're
gonna do something and then you stop
don't ever get to the point where you're
like i can't feel my heart
it doesn't work i've been working people
want they say they want my body and all
this stuff but i've been working out
consistently since i was 14 years old
right and i'm 44. i've been 30 years
years of hardcore two-hour workout 30
years yeah so it doesn't happen
overnight you just have to enjoy the
process totally learn to enjoy it
because i'm sure there was a point where
you started to enjoy losing 113 pounds
and that's the only way you're going to
keep going i've noticed something in my
life the people that are really good
want to work with the best people they
can find
hopefully people that are even better
than them
you know i mean that's my view of things
is if if you work with people that
aren't as good as you then you know you
become a country of midgets
if you work with people that are better
than you
then you really grow my dad did a style
of martial arts called kyokushinkai
and um
and i suppose this little boy trying to
get close to dad i was like well if he's
doing it i'm going to join him
so my dad and i shared this incredible
passion of martial arts and cars right
um
so i kind of get started you know with
my father then he gets gunned down when
i'm 13 years old and i went through like
a year of just nothing i just i couldn't
show up at the dojo i didn't have it in
me
and i did all the things we're talking
about the excuses at the time south
africa had a a particularly high crime
problem and i was like you know what's
the point you know he has a first degree
black belt who gets attacked he get
takes nine bullets and he's dead anyway
why am i going to this thing called the
dojo right
again excuses valid it really is
but there's no progress
so a year nothing
and then and then i was like i actually
miss it so i went back
it was interesting when i went back it
wasn't the same
i wasn't doing the qatar
to impress the senseis anymore
i was doing the cutter because i wanted
every single movement
to be as close to flawless as i could
get it
it changed my entire perspective so
one of the things that happened you're
going to love this i'm literally getting
chills thinking about it one of the
things that happened is time
just expanded
so right because we have a very finite
construct of time i'm going to be at the
dojo for an hour
but what happened was that hour be felt
like five hours and sometimes 30 minutes
felt like five
all of a sudden this fixed construct of
time
you know it started to change because my
relationship with what i was doing
changed
so it wasn't just a punch it wasn't just
the qatar i wasn't just i wasn't just
showing up for the emotion
i was embedded in every single part of
the process i was looking for growth for
progress right
i have to tell you that changed my
entire life
so anytime i find myself stuck now
i recognize that often the reason i'm
stuck is because i'm focusing on the
output and i'm not focusing on my input
right so output i've got to raise a
hundred million around for my business
output i've got to get 300 growth for
you know in customers output i've got to
get 25 yeah that's all output
but what you got to focus on is input
what are the things i've got to do and
how do i do those things intentionally
deliberately and try to get better every
single time every meeting every impact
conversation with one of my staff
members every engagement with a client
or a potential client every single one
of those things how do i focus on that
moment because actually the output is a
sum total of how those things come about
so when you when you are at the dojo and
you are being graded and you are going
through the process of trying to attain
your black belt or your brown belt
that's what everybody sees as the output
but what actually went in was that
malleable construct of time where you're
trying to perfect every single
movement imagination is more powerful
than knowledge when dealing with your
own mind and the mind of others if i
said to any of you come and stand on
this [ __ ] who would come and stand on
this chair
i'll give you a hundred dollars to stand
on this chair sure if i said well now
the chair
is that is on top of that spire on the
highest building in tallinn who's going
to climb up and stand on it for a
hundred dollars who would do that
some people would because they've got a
good imagination if i can stand on it
there i can send most people go no i
could fall you've got a little tiny
plank up here you can walk the plank
when it's on the floor
put the plank between two high-rise
buildings who's going to walk it
not many people because the
imagination that you could fall and kill
yourself is way more powerful than the
knowledge that i did this on the ground
it's wide enough
fear of flying
knowledge says it's actually the safest
place in the world the most dangerous
part of a flight is actually the drive
to the airport that's way more dangerous
than being in the plane do you think the
imagination cares we're going in a
flying coffin i'm hurtling through the
air and that guy looks like he's come
straight out of isis and he's in the bar
i think he's going to blow up the plane
and then you feel terrible the other
person's going i'm watching a movie i've
always wanted to watch the shape of
water this is so great
here's my time again to do nothing
so whatever you imagine would defeat
logic or defeat knowledge and when
dealing with children
people do logically why are you so bad
why can't you get it what's going on why
are you so naughty
and that doesn't work i never say to
kids why are you about to go what
happened to you the only thing i can
control my life are the things that i'm
willing to take responsibility for these
gladiators that came here thousands of
years ago and maybe lost their lives if
they took responsibility for the match
full responsibility and i might be
taking this too far right now i don't
know i don't know what it was like to be
a gladiator in 720 740 a.d okay i can't
even imagine fighting in front of 50 000
people with lines possibly coming out to
eat me okay but i know this you really
got to get this point carried away you
got to get it like in your head you're
an executive you're a business owner
you're a manager you're trying to hire
people you're trying to hire people and
you're like oh the people are bad
everybody's terrible everybody's bad i
can't find good people to take
responsibility we all have something to
do with what's going on around us
you and i authorize others to drop the
bomb look i've been robbed twice in my
life 23 years old i was almost killed
guy came in my house put a 45 caliber
pistol in my face hit me right here then
put 70 stitches in my head and face
robbed me
in new orleans louisiana i was robbed
at a younger age
i caused both of those i was the victim
in both situations
on the police report victim
robbed by
criminals truth is i wasn't a victim i
created both of those wrong place wrong
time wrong people i had something to do
with that
everything that happens to you is
because of you
quit passing it off
right it's going to rain on me right now
while i'm shooting this
dude that's my fault i could have shot
this thing yesterday when it was
sunshine watch and read high performance
people and you will see that they always
take responsibility when their life goes
to to garbage it's when they quit taking
responsibility the greats in the world
keep track of everything when they're in
the game
when they're the gladiator when they're
the ball player when they're the
executive of a big company they're
statizing everything okay how many
outbound how many inbound uh what's our
closing ratio what's our right ratio
everything is measured measure your
actions and measure your results those
that don't and won't are irresponsible
and they
will cause you problems
i remember as a young salesperson i was
keeping a log not on what i sold but on
what i said to people i kept everything
how many people i talked to how many
people i waited on how many people i
wrote up how many people i negotiated
with how many people i closed how many
people i talked to on the phone and also
what they said and what i said what
worked and what didn't work i was taking
responsibility this is the only way you
could take responsibility by the way
you can't just say oh i'm responsible
you got to do something to follow up the
responsibility
it's how i handle
and learned and became a professional
salesperson i handle the future by
handling by being responsible for the
present
you go in that gladiator you go in there
as a gladiator in that coliseum okay and
you don't figure out how you lost that
last fight you're gonna die in the next
one take responsibility even if the
other guy cheated
he surprised you he shocked you he
pulled out some of the weapon you didn't
know about be prepared for the future by
taking responsibility for the president
so be responsible be the cause not the
effect be responsible
even when you're not responsible be
responsible bad things happen to good
people good things by the way happen to
good people and blame no one be
responsible and remember this you want
to be great you want to be super
successful take responsibility for
everything
even the things that you could have no
responsibility the tax department which
every country has taxes
determined they want to know what kind
of income do you work for
so when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent parent to the child
they say is go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here
and the first thing you pay is the
highest taxes
because you worked for money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money
they punish you for that they want you
to hire employees or invest
okay so earned income is what they work
for the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if i buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand i sell it
for two hundred thousand hundred
thousand is capital gains if i buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest text
so the tax breaks that president trump
is working on today is primarily for
these guys here
so they're doctors lawyers
highly educated people
and they have stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff of
flipping houses you get a break but what
the really rich work for
is
passive income
and passive income
[Applause]
for me
i have a business
whether i work or not money comes in
and you've seen me i'm not here am i no
never never
i've heard my right not to be here
real estate i get milli half mil every
year my wife and i can we add more real
estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still get this but
this is another type of
income
this here i'll
get into is called phantom income
it's taxes i don't pay so it's a little
bit beyond most people's minds
but let's say my tax bill is a hundred
thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break
that means fifty thousand in taxes i
don't have to pay
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government it went back up
here
so that's what financial education does
it teaches you
about the financial statement which is
not taught in school again they teach
you fico scores which is really fido
scores
it was your total little dougie
okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching to work for now
ironically
when you save money and you have a 401k
this is the kind of income so savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better is the saving money in
what they call that 401 cases good
in this in canada it's called rrsp in
australia called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
i'm an active investor i don't buy this
because this is passive investors
i am active and i'm professional in all
of these areas
so i work for passive income which means
i'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year and you've seen kim and i
and your mother now
she's working on here
and so your mother's income keeps going
up your father's income keeps going up
and they don't have a job one time you
know as you know i went to indiana and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
when we had a good basketball team
we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue go hoosiers um
we would call somebody in bloomington
who would put a radio next to a speaker
phone and dial us and we'd sit on the
other side listening over a speakerphone
drinking our beer and whipping it up or
doing whatever and the internet was just
starting to happen and now i'm a tech
geek and i'm like into all of it
and we're like
there's got to be a better way to do
this and so one of my buddies from
indiana todd wagner was like look we've
been thinking about this and i'm like no
i'll figure it out i'm a networking guy
now and so we looked for ways to um
stream indiana basketball we called it
net casting back then over the brand new
internet
and so i went out and bought a packard
bell 90 megahertz computer and an isdn
line
and downloaded all the software and i
said you know what i'm going to figure
it out
and lo and behold by
oh golly early 1995 we had figured out a
way to
um we would we took these eight-hour
vcrs and connected it to a local radio
station record them we'd bring them back
go through this process called encoding
and put it up on this website we call it
audionet and then i'd go to any online
forum aol prodigy compuserve uunet
whatever it was or you use use usenet
and i like if you're interested in
dallas sports at all because we haven't
gotten to indiana yet if you're
interested in dallas sports go to this
website audionet and back then you had a
dial-up modem you had to download this
software called tcpip
and you had to have software from your
internet provider which meant that so
few people knew how to use it we had no
idea if it would work or not but all of
a sudden audionet went from 10 people a
day to 100 people to a thousand people a
day and as we added radio stations
they're getting calls from all over the
world from people who are listening to
their shows on demand not even lined and
then we worked with a company that put
together live software company called
zing
and we made it live and then everything
changed and that's really when streaming
was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed the name to
broadcast.com
went public and it was the biggest ipo
in the history of the stock market at
the time
um and then we sold it to yahoo what i
find interesting about you the way you
conduct your business is that when stuff
doesn't work out you apologize you go
and say we made i made a mistake and all
that what what is that the first time
you had to go out there and say sorry
this was wrong and it was i remember
with the increase the rate increase
right and then you were like oh forget
about it like what was that experience
like for you as a boss when you're like
i have to go and own this
going through marriage counseling 20
years ago
was really how i moved to become a
better manager and leader really and
yeah you know
this marriage counselor was able to get
me to see that i was often lying to
myself and to my wife you know saying oh
family is the most important thing and
i'd stay at work all night
and that the value of honesty is that
people can take honesty even if it's not
necessarily what they want to hear if
it's really sincere i'm a big believer
in the liberal arts education i think
it's overrated or it's underrated i mean
in that the computer science stuff is
overrated it's great technical skills
are amazing but
what has happened as i referred to
earlier is we've just all the
storytellers are kind of gone and the
actual understanding of our users is
gone we've lost all that sensitivity and
yet i feel like that sensitivity comes
first from really knowing yourself so i
encourage people to take classes not
just in art and music but in depth and
dialing dying and philosophy and
theology these things that you'll never
make money on directly but i think one
of the most important things you can do
is be interesting like i i only really
want to work with people who've not only
had those crappy jobs i talked about but
are also interesting they have stories
there's some meat to them there's some
flesh there's something really
compelling that's who you want to be
with if you're going to spend night and
day building something together that's
who you want to travel with these people
with these perspectives and these
stories and so
and interestingness is not something
that i think you're born with i think
it's achieved by vulnerability by
adventure by all these things and so i
really emphasize interestingness i think
you can get it from
from studying from reading from putting
yourself in uncomfortable positions uh
maybe more americans should just hang
out naked in saunas that could make them
more interesting
but
but traveling abroad going to ethiopia
and helping dig wells
that kind of stuff i think builds a much
more impressive character so stuart
butterfield who runs slack obviously one
of the most
successful investments in our portfolio
an amazing company
stuart is a liberal arts major
that dude is [ __ ] fascinating like
hanging out with that guy and talking
about anything beyond slack is amazing
he's canadian and he's got great
insights into us politics but you just
follow his snaps on snapchat the guys he
eats well he's checking out art he knows
music really well he's a really
interesting guy so he becomes a magnet
for talent you want to be around stuart
he enriches your soul and if you look at
the team of people he's recruited
superstars like april underwood prince
it's like he's really recruited an
incredibly deep bench of people because
they want to have authentic and
multi-dimensional relationships with him
and i think it comes through on the
product listen to me very closely a lot
of you could be millionaires
but because you're not disciplined he
pulls on a couple some of you you
because you you're not sexually
disciplined you've had people's take
stuff from you and you've been in places
and relate i just saw two young women
that lost their lives that was on some
dating thing and went to some man cr i
was like yo where they do that at
where do you just trust somebody online
that you don't even know
what was it about you that you were so
had so such a low self-esteem and it was
twins it was sisters that you just gonna
go to some men's house you don't even
know
come on then another young lady just
went to jail her man told her to he
killed somebody and she took a saw and
saw i'm like bully about to go to jail
it's with i'm like wow is it that love
that deep these days
people buying stuff i'm like well you
ain't grateful for god you gotta get the
extra hookups
i ain't mad at you but if you if you do
you understand what you're attracting
and then you mad when you ain't
attracting a
a successful man of character and
integrity in god but you're not putting
that out
okay i'm sorry
all right
listen to me very closely somebody yo
zero is gonna go to the next level when
you can learn to say no
i was just at a function my man was like
eat you did a phenomenal job bruh uh we
doing happy hour at 3 30. i said my
plane leave at 3 50.
he said you're not gonna stay for happy
i said bro i'm not here for no i don't
we don't know each other like that
happy hour i came to speak
i didn't come to build no relationship
with you
i didn't come to drink with you
drink bro i don't even drink and if i
drink i would drink at home i wouldn't
drink in front of you and get loose like
that and start talking crazy
you don't need to know me like that
you need to know me as the number one
motivational speaker in the world
flawless
i'm not but that's what you need to know
me as you don't even need to get close
enough to me to know my thoughts
this is a business transaction
yo you're going doing business with
people drinking like y'all what you're
being social for you don't have no
discipline drink when you get home you
just see some free wine
you see some free alcohol drink when you
get home this is business boundaries
there are boundaries my man like yo why
you got to go cause i'm married i got a
wife i'm going home we finished
we ain't got no more business to do you
told me we wanted a two-hour
presentation i did it i'm going home but
e this is a resort and
i'm going home why because i can't get
in trouble at home
i can't get in trouble at the crib i can
get in trouble at this resort
[Applause]
it's a lot of temptation at this resort
so i'm going home every year around
february march i say the same thing to
myself and i set myself the same goal
let's just stop there right and take a
look at what i just said because there's
a real clue in that first sentence why
does this goal pop up in march
the answer quite an obvious one because
summer is on the horizon
and you've got to ask yourself again
you've got to criticize yourself there
and say well why does summer matter well
because you know summertime is a time
where we wear less clothes we're a
little bit more vulnerable our bodies
are on show more and then you can ask
yourself okay so why is that relevant
well it speaks to the nature of my
motivation my motivation wasn't to work
out it wasn't to be healthy because i
want long-term health benefits or to or
to feel great about myself as
embarrassing as this is to admit my
motivation was so clearly
clearly
to look good for summer
let's just break that down a second
look good for summer looking good as a
goal is measured by just one thing the
public's opinion of me
ladies opinion of me
that's what we call an extrinsic
external goal success of that goal will
be achieved when the public think i look
good the next part of that sentence
right was for summer the next part of my
goal was for summer which is a
measurable time frame so once summer is
over
the job is done so the motivation behind
that goal was both extrinsic and held
within a time frame so when i dropped
that social media pick of me topless in
mykonos or wherever i went this summer
mykonos and costa rica looking good
during summer and when i got the
compliments the likes the followers the
praise and when summer passed
unsurprisingly
so did my motivation
job done
my goal my reason my why was attached to
summer and also public opinion and both
had been fulfilled so as i pulled into
october and i tried to find the
motivation to go to the gym it was gone
going to the gym suddenly felt so
pointless to me and i had no idea why it
just did even when i managed to get to
the gym my workout was quite honestly
pathetic it was short it was like 25 30
minutes of me predominantly texting and
i didn't know why i just thought i
wasn't feeling great like you know like
a boat that had suddenly been unanchored
i was now just drifting unconsciously
without intention or real motivation
or without conscious realization into
the winter months into bad habits into
fat steve and the minute i realized this
this year i was able to completely reset
and sort of re-anchor my motivation into
things that were intrinsically
internally motivating and without time
frames i set myself the goal of going to
the gym just because it makes me feel
great this particular investment we
bought a building for 17 million dollars
in houston
and it was a subsidiary of uh
boeing that tenant that occupied the
building and they handle all the
communication with the discovery shuttle
and i'm like they spent 20 million bucks
fiber optics this is so much
infrastructure they put in the building
they're not going to go anywhere that's
what the broker was telling me right so
we bought the building that had
five-year lease with three five-year
option and the cap rate was like eight
and a half so we put five million dollar
down and our return was like 20 18 to 20
percent cash on cash
whether you know boeing you know as as
your credit tenant was like how can you
go wrong and what are the chances of
you know nasa
not giving them the contract you know
renewing their contract you know it's a
government contract because they're the
main you know vendor
for
nasa and guess what happened
spacex you know came by elon musk and he
got awarded the contract three years
after i bought it i got a fedex uh
letter
and from our tenant usa which was the
name of the tenant they said oh we
didn't get the contract from nasa
renewed we're going to be moving out of
the building and my heart just dropped
i'm like
wow i just got punched in the gut oh my
god and that's all or none it was none
at that point and
sadly i had some partners in there i was
50 partner i put 2.5 million on my own
money then i had like 18 19 other family
friends that put money in there
which one of them you know yeah
and that was a hard thing for me to
swallow not i didn't care so much about
my money to be honest with you i i felt
uh more pressure and guilt for all these
other 18 because you know
i can always make the money back but
some of these people like my own sister
she bought money on her home 500 grand
and she put in there so all that money
was you know gone they got the
distribution for a couple of years so
they got some of that money back but
people always look at their equity they
pay oh yeah they don't care you know you
could make give them money for 10 years
distribution if they put a million bucks
they want a million back after 10 years
doesn't matter you know
[Music]
if you want seven more rich people
habits check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there focus on what's going on right now
in your life and how bad things are
that has all your attention
whatever has your attention
happens so if your attention is there in
a fair area it's going to continue that
way